Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to, Factorio!
Mark: I almost forgot-- I wanted to say Futuro for some reason.
[Bob Laughs]
Mark: Anyway.
Bob: That's not it...
Mark: Say hi, Bob!
Bob: Hey! How's it going?
Mark: Yeah, so Bob and I are back and I'm about to fuckulate everything because I just turned off.. (*wink*)
Bob: Ahh, I don't know what to do now.
M: Alright. It's okay. Just keep working on the science. We're - we're getting logistics in the next level -
- so we just need to upgrade logistics, and then we're going to be moving forward with everything else.
B: [whispers] I'm so lost...
M: You feel lost?
B: I feel lost inside, I do.
M: Why?
B: I don't know, I just do.
B being Egotist: Why do you care?
M: [laughs] Oh jeez, I- I thought I was your friend, but I guess not!
M: Holy crap!
[Bob chuckles]
M: This got off to a somber start!
B being Egotist: What the hell does it matter to you anyway?
[Mark laughs]
M: What does anything matter, in fact?
M: This is all bullshit anyway.
M: It's a fucking illusion.
M: Okay. Anyway, what I'm--what I'm doing is I'm making a, a line like this
because this way, I can have inserters...
uhh, moving the shit where it needs to go.
B: Mm.
M: Uh, in a line? Instead of having to manually fill it up all the time,
and then, with 3 steam engines it's gonna be a lot more power.
And then everything can move at maximum efficiency,
because what I wasn't realising is things were NOT moving at maximum efficiency.
B: We were very much under power?
M: Oh yes. VERY under power.
M: So, once we're at maximum power, like the, the uh, the electric miners,
they'll work with the power that you give them, but they won't work at maximum efficiency,
so you gotta make sure... that it's a hundred percent.
M: So this, if you left-click on a pole again now, you'll see that...
Production and consumption are exactly matched,
we still need-n-need more power.
M: Haah, hot tits.
[Bob laughing at Mark's choice of words]
M: Goddammit.
M: Maybe if I put more boilers on it?
M: I don't know how many boilers you can match up to a steam engine...
M: such that-
B: You could put another boiler on there, probably, couldn't you?
M: Yeah, I can? Let me see if this is gonna work. I have no idea.
B: Appears to be working.
M: Ahhh, but has power gone up?
M: Thank you, thank you!
B: Yeah, it went up a bit.
M: A little bit- Ahh, no. It's still 1.1, that was what it was before...
[Frustrated grunt] I don't know if, like-
There- there must be an upgrade, like down the road that'll help it do that more, so-
B: Couldn't we just put another steam engine up?
M: You're right, we could.
M: And I will do that.
M: No me. Ah fuck.
B: Haha, I did it.
M: You did it - you're the best.
M: You're better than me.
B: You got - you got enough - you got enough space there?
M: Yeah.
M: Ok, so everybody out there, now that we got enough power,
M: like I said everything's gonna be working at maximum efficiency.
M: And thusly --
M: We can have more production capacity.
B: Iiiiiit...
Did not go up.
M: It didn't go up? What? With four - Oh, that one's not connected to the grid, ok.
M: Boink! Aaaaand that should go up.
M: See it?
B: It did not go up.
M: WHAT THE TITTIES. This is bullshit!
B: How do we up production? Do we have to wire them in a certain way or something?
M: No, that should -
B: Do you need another pole?
M: That should be -
OH [scoffs] I'm an idiot. I only have one off-shore pump.
For four of these fuckers. I'm sohs -
B: Ohhhhhh.
M: I'm sorry, everybody out there. I'm a huge idiot.
B: Iiiinteresting.
M: Help me clear this forest out a bit more.
B: Okey-doke -- well, I'm stuck.
M: Yeah...
B: Stuck on all the things.
M: Actually it'd probably be better to do it over there
M: where you were - because --
B: Okey-doke.
M: ...it would be better -- yeah -- what?
M: W-what was I even thinking of?
M: Of course there was only one pump going to -
M: four of these bastards
M: Okay, let's see..
B: Will there - where's the pump?
M: It's in the - yeah
B: Ah - that's the pump
M: It's in the - uhh -- you - you see it.
B: I don't got no irons
M: Well, there's tons of irons
M: There's like - UNLIMITED amounts of irons
M: So if I...
M: do this like this and then have
M: more of these suckers...
B: Yeah, if you'd have all the pumps you need?
M: Uhh, I should...
B: Yeah, if you could have pumps
M: Yes, what the fuck?
M: What's in the way?
M: Uhh, oh, okay.
B: Is it this rock?
M: Nope, got it. Okay, we're good.
B: Oh, there you go.
M: Okay.
M: So that,
M: should ... allow us to --
B: Nope.
M: Nope? NOPE?!
M: Don't tell me, "Nope."!
B: [chuckling] Didn't do anything...
M: You -- you are lying to me
[Bob laughs]
M: if you're saying, "That didn't do anything."
M: that HAD to have done something.
B: [voice cracking from laughing] That didn't do anything -- click on the pole, man.
M: It- wEUHH????
M: There's no way it COULDN'T have done nothing.
M: It has to have done something.
[Bob's still laughing]
M: What?
B: Ah, ha - I don't know; I have no idea.
M: [unpleasant surprise] WHAT?!?!
M: It's LESS power [cracks up] now!
M: [Gasps]
M: What the hell?!
M:I am -
M: [Gasps]
M: thoroughly peeved - this - this doesn't
M; make any sense
M: Wonder what happens if I just -
M: m-
M: only one boiler per thing, here -
M: I know this is very boring
M: for everyone out there to watch -
[Bob laughs to the extent of that]
M: but I'm trying to think -
M: I'm not an expert at the game yet
M: by any capacity.
M: Okay, so that's exactly the same -
M: production capacity.
B: Oh, no.
M: What'd you do?
B: Umm.
B: Nnnnothing?
M: That was our defense!
M: You ruined our -
M: turret - they're gonna attack NOW
B: I - I got it, I got it -
B: it's fine.
M: Alright, are you sure?
B: No.
M: Okay.
M: Yeah, see, each of these things
M: should be able to -
M: pump out 510 kWs.
M: [Inhales]
M: So,
M: I'm guessing that would be if they were
M: exactly in line with each other
M: each with their - each INDIVIDUAL
M: offshore pump,
M: so that's what I'm going to do.
M: Oh, good! Logistics got done.
B: Jeez.
M: So, so -
M: hopefully that will give me the brain power
M: to be able to solve this, but -
M: no hopes, really, for that.
B: Yeah, let's not go crazy.
M: Oh. You could have SOME faith in me
M: y'know one of these times when I - [chuckles]
B: I mean - I mean you can do it Mark.
B: I'm confident at that you can do it.
M: One of these times when I insult myself
M: I just want to hear,
M: "No, Mark, no. You - you're trying really hard
M: "y'know, you're guiding us through this"
M: "experience, it's gonna be - it's gonna be good!"
M: "You'll be haPFHAPHAEMEE!"
B: Y - you're trying so hard, Mark.
B: You're ...
B: You can do it.
M: God, now I'm sadder
M: than I ever was before.
M:  Thank you.
[Chuckling]
M: Alright, hopefully we don't get attacked
[Bob cracks his knuckles]
M: right now ... because ...
M: Shit
M: [Whispers] Fuck
M: I'm gonna get this.
M: Okay.
M: Actually, what I'm gonna do -
B: Are, the turrets? Electric also?
M: Uh, no, actually.
M: Those turrets - if they'd have LASER turrets -
B: Oh, yeah.
M: would be electric, but those actually
M: run -
B: Those are fully functional turrets, man.
M: Yeah, they are SUPER cool.
B: So, I'm just gonna watch and ...
M: see what's going on here.
M: Okay, so what I've got going on here is ...
M: move plehehehehease!
B: [Snickers] Oh, okay?
M: Bob!
B: Alright.
[Mark laughs]
[Bob chuckles]
[Mark gasps]
M: What we've got here is
M: uhh
M: I've got each individual pump
M: is gonna go to its OWN
M: destination.
B: Jeez
M: And then they're EACH gonna provide
M: power
M: to the individual BOILERS?
M: so next to THESE bad boys.
M: And then
M: THESE are going to go like THAT.
M: actually, I'm going to make
M: 'Pipe-to-Grounds'
M: because 'Pipe to Grounds' allow me to put things
M: UNDERground
B: Oh, no, don't trap me in there!
[Bob snickers]
[Still snickering]
M: Aaand
B: I'm too stupid.
[Mark laughs]
M: "I'm too stupid to figure this out!"
M: You got it, Bob, though,
M: it's good.
M: Okay, so THAT
M: did
M: nothing
M: [Whispers] Fa --
M: FUCK!!!
M: That didn't work!
M: [Laughs under breath]
M: Okay, never mind!
M: I'm not gonna do that because
M: it's STUPID
M: and I actually didn't like it
M: and I didn't want to do it in the FIRST place.
M: Okay, if you --
B: [Snickers] Just, just tear 'em all up and --
[Bob chuckles]
M: If you could
M: put coal in them,
M: I'm not gonna --
B: They're fall - they're all full of coal.
M: Okay, thank you.
M: I've got WAY more coal  than I ever need.
B: I haven't got any POLES, though, so ...
M: [Whispers] I got it.
B: I'm out of poles.
M: [Still whispering] I got it covered.
B: [Now whispering] Okay.
M: So, we got one ...
[Bob laughs]
M: [Raises voice] Heeeere?
[Bob gasps]
B: [Raises voice] I don't understand how to make it more powerful
B: and I feel like this solution is not as complicated
B: as it seems like it might be
B: for us.
M: Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah
M: [Whispering again?] it's cool, it's cool, man
M: It's cool.
M: BOINK
M: [Clear voice] Okay.
M: So, NOW if we click on the pole,
M: it's going up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
M: aaaand it's less than it was bef --
M: [inhales in frustration]
M: [slams hand on desk]
M: [sighs]
M: [whispers in pain] Bob, I'm a failure.
M: [chuckles sadly] Bob, I'm a failure
[Bob laughs]
M: [voice cracking] Bob, I can't do it, Bob!
M: I'm a failure, I just --
M: I can't do it -- I can't -
M: [Slurs] I can't figure it out, man
M: [Sniffs]
M: There's just no way! It's impossible!
M: Okay, I know what - I know what to do.
M: [Stutters] It's a  - it's a ... it's a problem of boilers
M: I need more boilers is what I'm saying.
B: Mmhmm.
M: Yeah
M: So, what we gonna do-
M: is we're gonna put more boilers
B: I - I - I have so much confidence in you, Mark.
M: [Voice cracking] Thank you, Bob.
B: Uhh, I actually need to be ... right back
B: so you just go thinking about that.
M: Go ahead, go ahead. I'm thinking at it.
B: [While taking off his headphones] I'll be back.
[Holy Shit Piano]
B: [Grunts while scooting his chair]
Alright, do we have more power?
M: Uhh, no.
M: The problem is
M: ... I don't know
M: um ...
M: I'm - I'm gonna - I'm gonna redo all of that
M: What am - what am I - OH! There was Stone here!
M: Hidden in thee f -
B: Oh, God, dammit.
M: Look! There's like two Stone here.
M: Oh, ho, ho, that's adorable.
B: You'd find that everyday?
M: Well, how would we have known?
M: It was buried under an entire forest
M: Least I'm getting plenty of wood
M: Y'know, all the good I can do with the wood in this game.
[Bob chuckles]
M: God, dammit, stop --
[Bob still chuckling]
M: There's so many Goddamn trees
M: I can't even click on the Goddamn right one.
B: Alright, let's see if it went up at all
B: with two more of these fuckers on here
M: Ooookaaay
B: It did not. [Chuckles]
M: Why is it not?! That doesn't make any sense!
B: [Still chuckling] Don't know what you're say -
M: That's impossible!
B: Do we need to just separate the grids?
M: I did - it'd - how? What did - ?
B: What if we...
B: What if we separate the grids so that, like,
B: uhh
B: oh, gosh, I dunno
B: like, what if we separate this off
B: and then
B: connect down this way?
M: Bluech!
B: And so, these guys are powered
B: only by that one grid?
M: Uh, huh?
Okay?
B: Maybe?
M: Let's see. Oh, God.
B: Oh, my gosh.
M: Lag.
B: Whatever I just did made it SO angry.
M: Heh, heh!
M: It's REALLY thinking about it.
B: I'm really sorry, video game
M: Oh, God, what have you done?!
[Both laughing]
M: Okay, there we go. We're back.
M: Nope! We're not!
M: Okay, there we are.
M: We're su - we're chugging along.
M: It's - it's REALLY thinking about it.
[Bob groaning]
M: Ohhhohohohoh
B: Okay.
B: Apparently, I just found a horrible, horrible thing.
[Mark laughing]
B: And how I'm really sorry.
[Mark groaning]
M: [Still groaning] Geuh!
M: I'm just struggling to pick up call!
B: Okay!
B: [Voice cracking] It's okay!
M: Aaaaahhhh!!!!
B: [Breaking to laughs]
M: It's like the frame rate hasn't dropped at all -
M: it's literally the server has just, like,
M: [Deep inhale/exhale/inhale]
M: [Voice cracking] Oh, God!
B: Why are you doing this?
B: I don't understand!
M: Okay.
M: Alright, so
M: there's obviously some THING
M: that's stopping us from ...
M: geh - it's like
M: uh - I - I even like hover over a minute, it says like
M: the "performance"
M: is super LOW for each of these?
M: Maybe the problem is like the double boiler system
M: maybe the double boiler is just ...
M: completely wrong.
M: Maybe it just needs to be one boiler
B: Yeah,  cause I separated
B: I think I separated the grids ...
B: Oh, no, they're not separate. Oh, God.
M: Hang on ...
B: It doesn't matter
B: I'll adapt to this.
M: Yeah, hah. It ...
[Mark chuckles]
M: Man, here comes Depressed Bob, again!
B: It's - it's just ...
B: It's all -
B: it's all a lie.
M: "It's all a lie"?
B: Nothing even ...
B: nothing - OHHH
B: HAHHH
M: You okay down there?
B: Eh, yeah. I was just joking around for a little bit.
M: Okay. Yeah. I think it will smart out eventually, but -
B: Mark,
B: I da - I don't know if we're really gonna UP the efficiency.
B: I just don't know if that's meant to happen.
M: Welp,
M: There - there [scoffs]
M: we can't up the efficiency, but we can up the POWER
M: there HAS to be a way to up the POWER
M: this doesn't make s-
M: in all my games when I was playing by myself,
M: this worked,
M: like, it DID, it just DID
[Bob chuckles]
M: [Whispering] This doesn't make any sense
M: [Clear voice] Alright, I'm going to break everything down again,
M: And I'm [laughing] going to try one more time,
M: and this gonna work.
M: I'm gonna do
M: wanna do LITERALLY the thing that I was doing in the other -
M: AWWWWWWWWW
M: 'KAY.
M: There we go.
M: I'mma do literally the thing that I was thinking about in the other
M: uhh, in my other playthrough, where I played for HOURS
M: and I had lots of POWER, and everything was FINE.
M: [Bob chuckles]
M: But in this one ...
M: is just a ...
B: And everything was just ...
B: swimming - swimmingly - swimming along?
M: Yes. I don't want the uh - OHHHHH
B: Oh God
B: Oh, no.
M: I wish I had known you'd be doing that.
B: Oh, jeez.
M: Yeah.
M: And I think this is gonna do it.
M: Because -
M: up there is a little bit -
B: Oh, turned off the thing, okay.
M: Y - yeah ...
B: Oh, my God, all the tower flats were deleted!
[Laughter]
M: Yes!
M: Hopefully, this will solve ALL our problems.
M: Okay, so, what I recall from what I was doing before,
M: is ... ?
M: I had ...
M: basically ...
M: I had one pump per TWO machines.
M: And I had them splayed out on either side
M: aaaaaas, such as this.
M: like - kssssssssss ...
B: And? Like? Such as?
M: And like, such as this.
M: Like, THAT
B: Alright?
M: So,
M: and then I have the offshore pump
M: like right
M: such as THAT
M: we move this in
M: wait. I - I need to figure out where this gonna land
M: before I ... figure anything else out.
M: But, then I just had, like, a boiler on thee - on the
M: butt ends of each of these
M: so I WENT a little like ...
[A quiet motorcycle impersonation ]
M: shIT. LYYYYYKE...
M: THAT.
M: And I had a SPLIT in between the two.
B: Mm.
M: Put some of THEESE
M: SHOULD
M: let's JUST see how much power THIS produces.
B: There ya go.
M: And this produces -
M: Look at THAT! That's the power
B: Wow
M: we were working with before, right?
B: yeah, and actually
M: yeah!
B: The c-consumption is slightly less than that.
M: Yeah!
B: Is everything powered right now?
M: Yeah but the consumption could be higher if we had more power.
M: So I'm going to do this exact set up again elsewhere,
M: and it's gon' ta be good.
M: Riiiiighttt?
B: In theory, why not?
[Mark Laughs]
M: In theory, everything is beautiful.
B: In theory....absolutely.
B: Chugachugachugachuga...steam..chugachuga                                                                      M: Okay..
M: Anndd thusly like this thus
M: And...oo....okay
B: I put- I put coal in the boiler so I helped.
M: Okay thank you, thank you.
B: I said I put cool in the boilers cause that's not the right word.
M: Aaaa- okay I'll allow it.
[Bob laughs]
M: Okay..and there we go and now the power iiissss
M: Not up!
B: Wait wait wait, Mark, wait, hang on-
M: Uh-huh... ok.
B: So the- the production...
B: Is at.. The exact same as the consumption, right?
M: Yea.
B: But there's a lot more of the production bar that's not filled in.
M: Uh-huh-
B: Which means that the consumption is,
B: Eating everything that it needs, and we're only using one-third of our current cap-capaacity-
B: On the production... Right?
M: Yea.
B: So our production is actually,
B: About 2100 Kilowatts.
M: Yea-
B: It's just-
M: Yea...
B: So we are making more power this time..
M: Yea..
B: So we may have been making more power before and just been too stupid to realize.
M: I think you're right.
B: *quick giggle*
M: I think this has just been fucking with us.
B: *another giggle* I think we just don't know how to read graphs.
M: Oh ho, its only been - OHHHHHHHHH
M: OOOOOOOHHHHHHHH
B: *giggles*
M: Thatttttttt is rightttttttt!
M: Ahhhhhhhhhh!
B: *chuckles*
M: Ahhhhhhh I'm so stupid!
B: *heavy breathing and more giggling*
M: Ohhh my god!
M: WELL
M: Shit
B: *slowly dying from lack of oxygen due to too much laughter*
M: Okay.
B: I can't, I just cant.
M: Thank you, thank you Bob.
M: You've helped us out incredibly.
M: Ahhhh I'm such a tit.
B: Man that ahhhhhhhhhhh
B: That does not look good, for us.
M: *laughs*
M: Soo we just spent, uh, an entire episode
M: Trying to figure out what the hell we were doing with that.
M: Ok!
M: Well.
M: Ummm..
M: So..
B: *Bob trying not to loose his mind*
B: I mean *sighh*
M: Anyways B: Ok what
B: We figured it out
B: In the end, I think what's important
B: Is that we figured it out.
M: Yeah.
M: But what else is important I think
B: We need to give the people watching like
B: 5 more minutes of productive time?
M: Which would be lovely.
B: So we have - we have so
B: So so so so
M: So, ok yes
B: So we have logistics.
B: What the hell do we do with logistics?
M: Ok, so
B: There's that.
M: So logistics is basically
M: In your logistics crafting tab, we got
M: What are called 'underground belts' and 'splitters'.
M: When you have incoming cargo,
M: A splitter with spread it onto two different conveyor belts,
M: One to one.
M: So if you have like
M: The iron and coal on this line it will split it
M:Into two different lines
M: And then those will go in different directions.
M: Same with the copper and stuff.
M: But that's for more intricate builds.
M: So the more interesting thing is that we have fast inserters
M: And long handled inserters.
M: So they will go distances that they
M: Can drop things off from far away or close.
M: So those will help out in making bigger and more complicated routes.
M: But before we do that
M: We need, uh, to finish up electronics
M: And then we need advanced material procesings.
M: So right now,
M: We're doing very well on this front,
M: But the next steps in production are
M: What are called 'assembly loops'.
M: And uh, this is
M: I'll just generally make
M: What I call
M: An assembly loop,
M: And you'll judge and see if its actually anything worth bragging about.
M: Which, admittedly, it probably won't be because its a horrible design
M: And no one should be proud of it.
M: But we're gonna try it.
M: So the basic of an assembly loop
M: Is these assembly machines
M: Will make things with two parts
M: I would like to have the next level up
M: Which makes things with three parts
M: And I'm actually gonna replace this with a
M: Fast inserter as soon as these assembly machines
M: Are done
M: Um actually you can do that. Can you replace the uh,
M: instead of having two of these things
M: And that's actually pretty cool with the looping system there
M: But, Can you replace 'em with the blue ones
M: Which are called 'fast inserters'
M: and they move, wicked fast!
B: And- Replace thee overflow
B: uh, grabbers?
M: yeah all the overflow grabbers
B: Oh my God
M: Yeah he moves bitchin fast and I think thats actually going to be enough to overflow all of it
Mark: So he should be good with that
Bob: That is fantastic
Mark: I know right
*WEIRD BOB AND MARKIMOO NOISES*
Mark: They do produce, erh, consume a little more power, but they're waaay better for eveything we need.
Bob: So much wiggly waggly.. I love it! Mark: I know right..
Mark: yeah. So now that we got power
Mark: and now that we got this and now that I have assembly
Mark: machines, so basically,
Mark: an assembly loop
Mark: is... you put four
Mark: in a.. err..
Mark: no wait hang on. You put four in a square
Mark: like that. And then you take conveyor belts
Mark: to move them around each other.
Mark: So you basically have...
Mark: What looks like...
Mark: This.. Not like that.
Mark: What looks like this
Mark: Whoops, shit. Sorry, little drunk.
Bob: *laughs* Mark: Like thhhhhh
Mark: hhhhhhhiiiii
Mark: iis?
Bob: Yeah, yeah. Mark: like this,
Mark: like thiiiii
Mark: iiiis aaaa
Mark: aand. Almost
Mark: I ran out of conveyors. Shit
Mark: God dammit Bob: I got it, I got it.
Mark: Like thaaaaaa
Mark: aat. Bob: That's.. Hang on I ran out of conveyors too.
Mark: Dammit! Mark and Bob: * laughs * Mark: Alright I got it
Mark: Hang on.. The, like that. Bob: Okay.
Mark: Okay, so now..
Bob: Yeaaah. Mark: We have those and,
Bob: Cool. Mark: well, what we're gonna do is, I'm gonna make
Mark: a science.. loop.
Bob: Sweet. Mark: So there's ONE thing making
Mark: gears, and that
Mark: just needs steel. And then there's
Mark: the rest that are making science,
Mark: Literally just the red science packs
Mark: and this is very basic. So we
Mark: need an input,
Mark: and that comes from inserters
Mark: moving things in.
Mark: So we need.. ahh..  what
Mark: what we need are twoo chests
Mark: ..cause we it..
Mark: the thing that this thing needs is, copper
Mark: and it needs steel plates, or iron.
Bob: Well I have two chests. so.. Mark: Okay
Bob: Where should I put them? Mark: So. Bob: Like down here? Mark: Yeah.
Mark: Just put it two away,
Mark: so that we can have inserters putting them in there.
Bob: Yup. Mark: Yeah.
Mark: So then we have inserters pointing in the
Mark: inward direction, wiith. Bob: Okay.
Mark: The pole going right there.
Bob: Oh. I was gonna, okay. Mark: It's cool I got it.
Mark: It's cool. And then we put
Mark: copper in one and..
Bob: I got a whole bunch of stuff on me. Mark: Yeaah.
Mark: So copper in one and then iron in the other.
Mark: So that one is copper,
Mark: and that one has iron. So
Mark: when we put in more
Mark: inserters.. not burner inserters.
Mark: Why do I have burner inserters?
Mark: I do. Bob: So I should put, I should put
Bob: Uhh. Inserters
Bob: into everything? Mark: Yes.
Mark: In going inwards, and I'll
Mark: put the power poles. Bob: Okay.
Mark: And then, also going outwards.
Bob: Oh, okay.
.... Mark: And
Mark: electronics Bob: So I need, Mark: just got finished. Bob: Oh, I'm not, I'm completely
Bob: out of stuff. * laughs * Mark: I got one more, I got
Mark: I got it, I got it. So in
Mark: and then out. So
Mark: the out ones put it on the far
Mark: side of the loop. So that all the
Mark: output is on the far side. And then the
Mark: in ones will just keep the
Mark: materials on the inside, so that there's
Mark: always like, copper and steel
Mark: as needed. Bob: Oh.
Mark: So, as you can see..
Mark: Three of them are producing..
Mark: uh.. Science, and they
Mark: output science in a giffy,
Mark: as soon as it starts producing its first
Mark: one. And there! See? On the belt! You got
Mark: one science! Bob: So now we just
Bob: need a splitter to get the science
Bob: off of that belt onto its own collection belt?
Mark: Ah. not quite. We can.
Mark: We just.We just finished making
Mark: electronics. Which has a
Mark: a smart inserter. So if you make a.. Bob: Oh shit.
Mark: smart inserter,
Bob: Yes, I will make one. Mark: Yeah.
Bob: And then I will place that. And then
Bob: I will also make a chest, to put stuff
Bob: in it. Mark: Yeess Bob: I, I
Bob: figuring things out
Bob: inside Mark: Uh huh. Bob: my brain hole. Mark: *laughs *
Mark: You're doing great Bob. You're doing
Mark: inside that eight year old brain it's cool.
Mark: So put the smart inserter down,
Mark: and then, Bob: Hope there's red science.
Mark: Yeees, exactly.
Bob: I'm all about that shit.
Mark: Okay, then I'll just power it.
Mark: Okay, the power got ugly. Bob: Oh my god.
Bob: * laughs * Mark: But it's ugly on your side
Mark: so I think that's fine.. Bob: It's, It's my fault. Mark: * laughs *
Mark: Okay, so, this is what you do!
Mark: This is all you need to do, because now you have
Mark: a constant supply, so long as you
Mark: keep the chest filled.
Bob: That's fucking amazing. Mark: Yeah!
Mark: So it's a compact, little design that's gonna produce
Mark: ALL the red science that we
Mark: could possibly need. Bob: That's fucking
Bob: amazing. Mark: Make sense? Cool!
Bob: Mark.. It's amazing.
Mark: Thank you. I was just looking for self
Mark: affirmation. Bob: I'm honestly pretty
Bob: stoked about this though, like,  Mark: Yeah.
Bob: it's very much just gonna do itself
Bob: its gonna do its own business genes right now.
Mark: Yeah. But cool right? So you just
Mark: keep building assembly loops like that or
Mark: better designs, there, assembly loops its just,
Mark: what I figured out could be made,
Mark: and the whole game is freezing up, Bob: Yeah. * laughs *  Mark: But
Mark: it's just what I figured out could be made
Mark: it's really cool every, but
Mark: this is just one solution to the problem.
Mark: In this game you can make any solution to the problem that you want.
Bob: So. Literally Bob: Right. Mark: whatever your imagination.
Mark: You could do this with splitters, underground, uh,
Mark: conveyor belts, you can have things
Mark: going all over the place it can be nuts. Bob: I think we're going
Bob: to the problem of the belt eventually
Bob: filling up with copper. Mark: Yes.
Mark: It will, it will do that.
Mark: And uh. The problem with that one is, uh.
Mark: That's where
Mark: the, the. This is why
Mark: I said this is shitty. This is a terrible design.
Bob: I got, I got this. Mark: It's literally the worst.
Mark: Yeah? Okay.
Mark: Ah!
Mark: Speed up the iron.
Bob: Hopefully at least it fills in
Bob: gaps that exist with iron and then
Bob: keeps the balance. Mark: a, and thats smart because
Bob: Yes. Mark: it'll do it before the copper gets in there.
Bob: Mhm. So it'll fill as many iron
Bob: spots that others can't. Mark: Yeah.
Mark: Okay, but, anyway this is all the time
Mark: that we have for this episode. THANK YOU everybody so much for watching
Mark: thank you Bob for joining us for this one.
Bob: Oh yeah. Mark: Yeah. And hopefully you guys are
Mark: enjoying at home, so thanks again. And as always..
Mark: we'll see you.. IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
Mark: BUH BYE!
* outro music * Mark: Spouting splashing soaking innards
Mark: ingests invoking. nailing never
Mark: stops the choking. Well then..
Mark: Well I'm just a smoke monster whatever that may be..
Mark: Okay, that, that didn't work.
*ending of outro music *